the Joe Rogan experience I think it's a
good idea I was joking around but also
being serious like what you were saying
you could do for plants why not why
wouldn't you do it for yourself why
wouldn't you I mean y'all felt
everything is made up of things we can't
see
self love right self-love is the most
important thing you can express and I
think if you don't love yourself the
breakdown in the chain is you know we're
talking about this whole podcast we've
been talking about like trauma and pain
and along that life time what determines
one person becoming a Joe Rogan or Joey
Diaz or even you know somebody who goes
on to become a politician or doctor
whatever it is what determines them
going from that direction to people who
are committing crimes and yeah for sure
there's something on a on a microscopic
multi cellular level that is determining
these things and in self-love is is a
tool to use to sort of I think help help
you put yourself on the trajectory of a
positive life yeah not green but think
it's just it's hard for people to just
change gears right it's hard for people
who aren't healthy to be healthy it's
hard for people don't eat well eat well
it's hard for people who are kind of
lazy to get their [ __ ] together and be
disciplined you're gonna get tired you
know and if you're that person that
automatically seeks comfort and
Nothingness all the time anyway it's
gonna be hard for you yeah it's gonna be
really hard yeah what are your what are
your reinforcements and what are you
reinforcing this is where I think events
are very there's amazing opportunity in
events and this is a big event what do
you mean
events like this pandemic okay I was
thinking of my guru terrible I miss like
you know events and going out oh I see
what you're saying this pandemic this
moment in time where everything stops
and there's like okay like have you
watched any television since then and
see people without masks and see people
hugging and shaking hands you go ah ah
right are already we've only been on
lockdown for a month or so and already
we freaked out when we see people hold
hands and movies we see people kiss
people they barely know you like
it's changing behavior yeah it's it is
scary because this is what I've been
telling people forever when it comes to
places like China people like I can't
believe that China is military
dictatorship in 2020 yeah and if you're
not careful that could happen here oh
absolutely that can happen anywhere if
you're lazy enough but it's here's we
have to understand this if it exists
anywhere it can exist here and we get
all complacent in this idea that that
could never happen to us and we're too
[ __ ] smart do you know how many
people are rethinking their thoughts on
safety on security on guns on the food
chain the food supply chain people are
rethinking just basic survival well
that's scary yeah and it becomes that
sort of desperation factor and the isn't
this like we were talking about you know
us being so comfortable we're due for
some [ __ ] well this is it I mean this is
due for some destruction there's a trial
run because this ain't [ __ ] compared to
a big earthquake or if an asteroid hits
like there's a big asteroid that's
flying by it's a mile wide and it's
gonna fly by earth soon a mile wide do
you know what a mile wide piece of rock
from space would do if it hit us it's
it's a planet and I would think it would
it would leave a dent or two it's a
planet Endor lining maybe the silver
lining is that we're getting a little
bit of a taste of what a real you know
more devastating global pandemic looks
like in that's gonna be the deciding
factor on our preparations for something
in the future occurring yeah they didn't
know but now they do so now that they do
there better be plans in place for all
those other possibilities like those
super volcanoes like yeah we better
destroy it impacts we better re
reintroduce the pandemic Department and
get those [ __ ] their job back well we
don't even know if they really went away
I mean it is very accurate
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] we're
all of you you're great [ __ ] I love me
too
but this this is now we understand that
the way things have been is not
necessarily the way things always will
be definitely
not things can get a whole lot weirder
so we should be [ __ ] careful we
should be careful but we should also be
grateful I think this is a silver the
silver lining hopefully will be us
learning how to prepare a little bit
more in in you know not argue and debate
over these stupid things that don't
[ __ ] matter right but I think the
reason why we're going on and on about
stupid [ __ ] was because we didn't have
something like this because life was too
easy
yeah well [ __ ] it's never good
complacency breeds contempt right and
that's on a global scale scale
oh yeah yeah that as well Lisa C was it
breed complacency is it I just make up a
cliche complacency makes fat asses not
the P H kind complacency is a dangerous
thing does anybody say P H fat anymore
that's not real anymore right that's fat
that was like the 90s early googling
this contempt was the first thing
failure family operty complacency breeds
mediocrity or contempt Oh interesting
so familiarity breeds contempt and
complete see everything is breeding
we're familiar with our complacency yeah
well we need to know what's important
and I think now we do have a better
sense of it so a real question is
whether or not we can learn because
people are good at a justments when they
have to make adjustments then when
things slide back they get this sort of
the thing we were talking about earlier
where you don't want to look at all the
possibilities because you will freak out
especially if you're doing animals hell
yeah I've been staring away steering
away from the edibles I mean I have been
doing the blunts but I think people will
change when their livelihood and
survival threatened yes but will they
change to protect themselves or will
they change to adapt a new way of life
to protect the greater good because I
want to be on a earth of people who are
protecting human race not Bob Johnson
you know what I mean not an individual
right because it's then we're just back
at square one well though if you look at
the history of people we're doing way
better now the
we were before right we keep doing
there's obviously been some peaks and
valleys and some mistakes and we're also
also aware that you can kind of navigate
the future intelligently and if you
navigate the future intelligently you
make less and less mistakes I think we
just now have to reassess the nature of
our momentum the nature of the society
that we're creating and what what we're
trying to do
[Applause]